welcome to double feature week a video
Monday and a video coming Thursday but
before I get to some exclusive audio
with the president of MTV I need to
update you on the Jon Stewart situation
now as many of you know I created a
video in which I released a private
email from a senior producer at The
Daily Show in which they said we never
booked conservative pundits those aren't
sarcastic quotes they're real quotes
well it caused quite a stir enough for
mr. Stewart himself to be upset and said
producer 2 furiously call my manager
turns out it was an email sent to him
not to me long story short he made it
known that he had mouths to feed and he
would have to put some distance between
himself and I in order to maintain a
viable career listen folks he is a
really good man and I don't blame him
one bit also The Daily Show is a private
entity they can book whomever they want
and exclude whomever they want they
don't owe anybody anything now let me be
clear Jon sports both hilarious and
brilliant and the reason the folks Daily
Show are upset is not because of regret
for their discriminatory policies or not
because it was dishonest there's no
dispute whatsoever as to what was in the
email but because the curtain has now
been pulled back on Jon Stewart the man
has made a career off of accusing others
of harmful bias see to me it seemed that
Fox was a relentless agenda driven
24-hour news pinion propaganda delivery
system covered with the finished
possible patina of objectivity that
would allow them to claim a mantle of
totally undeserved legitimacy and so he
doesn't want you to see this see John
will tell you that there's nothing he
hates more than partisan politics your
partisan what-do-you-call-it
hacks
but but but see the thing is we need
your help
you're right now you're helping the
politicians and the corporations and
we're left out there we're too rough on
them when they make mistake on them
you're part of their strategies see John
would never help a politician plus he
makes funny faces so we know when to
laugh see John his producers don't like
the fact that he's been pointed out as
arguably the single most biased figure
in news media or entertainment because
that disrupts the whole moderate
narrative we will gather on the National
Mall in Washington DC a million moderate
March where we take to the streets to
send a message to our leaders and our
national media that says we are here
we're only here though until 6:00
because we have a sitter see he says
he's a moderate but someone disagrees
with that no it's not me it's his boss
Doug Herzog this next exclusive audio
comes to us courtesy of Ben Shapiro
what do you make of all the controversy
surrounding Jon Stewart and accusations
that he's been you know very very soft
on Barack Obama well-being
well there you have it
not only do Hollywood immediate have a
bias that they attempt to hide at all
costs but they also operate through a
system of instilling fear into both
talent and representation in order to
stifle voices of dissent and selectively
edit the national dialogue while they
pose as nothing more than moderates but
at least they make funny faces